ikaw our sponsors nature's blend
producers of premium Ethiopian black
seed products if you put her job 10
you'll get 10% off your purchase check
out their links underneath in the
description box I have a lot of
unanswered questions there are things
that bother me they worry me I think one
thing I've learned and I learned this
from Gary Habermas a a mentor of mine I
would come to him and I'd say well what
about this and what about this and he'd
say did Jesus rise from the dead yeah
okay well why is that bothering you okay
so you know yeah but there's debate
today amongst scholars who wrote Matthew
did Matthew actually write the Gospel of
Matthew well Mike did Jesus rise from
the dead yeah well if Matthew didn't
write Matthew would Christianity still
be true if Jesus rose from the dead yeah
well then why is it bothering you so
much
Bart Ehrman we've had five debates he
and I and he would point out all these
different contradictions and errors in
the Bible and I'd say well I don't grant
those to you Bart but look if Jesus rose
from the dead if Jesus rose from the
dead Christianity is true even if it
were to be the case that some things in
the Bible aren't and he agreed just like
well what's the big deal then so that's
the response that it has provoked for me
I've used these so yes I have a lot of
unanswered questions yes there are some
things in the Bible that trouble me
honestly I don't like to read the Old
Testament so but I've I've learned to
put things into perspective
you guys just saw there this guy hmm
Mike Michael and Kona
if I'm pronouncing his name correctly
I've just had gotten to know who he is
actually he's a big player apparently in
the Christian speaking world obviously
next it was William Lane Craig hmm
anyway look I mean why I just wanted to
make a quick reaction video on this
because I just found that for someone
who's meant to be one of the scholars of
the Christian faith in english-speaking
world how can you come up with such from
your own perspective blasphemous
statements like you're saying I don't
like reading the Old Testament but isn't
the Old Testament scripture is in your
Testament the Word of God isn't the Old
Testament according to you you know
comprising of not just the five books of
the Torah in the beginning but also the
words of the prophets and people who
have been given revelation from God
how could you not like reading that if
you're a true Christian
and then you're saying well if Jesus
rise from the dead then Christianity is
true
what you mean if Jesus duck rise from
the dead in Christianity is true if
you're casting aspersion on the validity
of the Bible in and of itself including
the Old Testament
why don't we we can do the same thing
now with textual analysis at the New
Testament how do you know Jesus rose
from the dead how did you know Jesus was
the promised messiah that was that was
prophesized in the Old Testament if you
don't like reading the Old Testament if
it's not something we should take
seriously so you see it's a circular
argument and it's problematic on many
different levels and I think that this
is an indication of especially in the
apologetic world and we have it as well
as our community the Muslim community
where apologists get battered yeah they
get battered so hard on certain issues
usually moral issues that they throw the
baby are out with the bathwater
so in this case
I'm not gonna mention names from our
community we do have people that do the
same thing as this guy's done here but
you've just found a baby outta Buffalo
well Scripture you've got nothing my
friend did you get it if you don't have
it is the thing your principles and
doctrines are you are you giving me a
Catholic rendition of is this meant to
be a Catholic rendition where the
community and the ecumenical councils of
the patristic elders in the early
Christian Christian period with the
crystallization of the doctrines of the
Trinity etc are DS is that the authority
or is your for invested in the scripture
as a Protestant how can you even make
the claim that yeah that you don't like
to read the Old Testament so you see I
feel like this is you throwing the baby
out with the bathwater and because
you've been battered in the in in the
apologetics world where people tell you
how can you have a verse telling you
that you can smash the baby's head on
the rock or whatever okay and going into
these things in it that discomforts you
to know that Jesus Christ who you're
saying is God
Jesus Christ you you're saying is God it
discomforts you to know that he's the
one who ordered you know the young girls
to be taken book of numbers that he one
verse a whoever is where he looked a
book you know to be taken after you've
destroyed everything in the land and we
don't even need to go into the Old
Testament rhetoric because it's very
well-known okay maybe it discomforts you
to look at the creation story and it's
conflicts with modern science or maybe
it discomforts you to look at yeah other
issues
relating to the the the prophets and how
they dealt with you know their daughters
their mothers their sons that wherever
it may be incestuous relationships of
law and this and then other prophets
maybe these things really just come for
you but the thing is then aren't you not
doing the battle there's a guy called
mattheum yeah he was one of the
patristic if you look at it from church
farmer perspective he was actually quite
early on he wasn't a church father
because he wasn't considered part of the
church if you want to use that term as
if there was some kind of unity of the
church in the early days there wasn't
but there's a sky khon Marcia who
basically believed that being and he was
an early so-called he's not they would
consider him a obviously Christians
would consider him
and obviously we were this was Muslim
see he would consider him as a as a
heretic but he said that you know you've
got to kind of God the God of the Old
Testament the evil God and then the god
of the New Testament who kind of is the
loving God and comes and takes us away
from
you know the clutches of this evil God
and it's almost as if this this lacunae
I'm sorry if I'm pronouncing his name
right wrong is affirming this narrative
now what I found was really interesting
I'm not saying to that level but he's
affirming that narrative what I found
interesting is William Lane Craig who's
menifee he is an eminent scholar in the
religion of philosophy of religion he
didn't correct him and this is even more
disturbing if you think about it because
these guys are just well this makes me
feel like now the Christian world is is
is reaching such a decline period
there's a decline period now in terms of
Christian apologetics and Christian
what'd he call it faith spreading
missionary work and so on especially in
Western Europe it's reaching such a low
that these guys are willing to throw the
baby out with the bathwater and willing
to change their religion completely now
he said if Jesus rise from the dissin to
the argument is such a is such a
ridiculous unscholarly argument he goes
if Jesus rose from the dead then
Christianity is true all right if you
believe Jesus rose from the dead but
then influence for the sake of argument
you believe in a new prophet called
Prophet Muhammad Salla is still true
that's my quest my honest question to
you because what you didn't think about
is additions to that belief yeah just
because you believe Jesus rose from the
dead is that is that all it is so your
faith is based on a historical event so
as a historian if I look back and say
you know what I doubt the existence of
the Resurrection and by the way there
are good well-qualified historians here
in the West that not only doubt the
crucifixion and the resurrection but
they doubt the whole existence of Jesus
Christ now as a Muslim I don't doubt the
existence of Jesus Christ as a Christian
I'm true you know neither
but the point is why should faith be
predicated on a historical event which
can easily rationally be half of two
thousand years ago and it won't cuz I
don't believe it you guys are not all of
you guys but a lot of you guys deny the
existence of dinosaurs you say look the
fossil record the archeological fossil
record has been well you know the devil
put those fossils in place whatever may
be that you guys say not all of you
young age creationists for example some
of them I've heard those conspiracy
theorists and point is you can have
those beliefs but if you're willing to
put cast aspersion on the fossil record
to that level then why why is it not
reasonable for someone to cast aspersion
on this historical event of the
resurrection say well we have eyewitness
testimony so no problem we have
eyewitness testimony you have this you
have that whatever and by the way I'm
not even going to go into the
contradictions in the four Gospels the
synoptic Gospels and so on and and how
these contradictions are problematic for
historians yeah
forget about for Muslims and Christians
and Jews and whatever for in saurians
that look at the date are they say
support of my and more even gonna go
into that that that janab that
that matter well I'm gonna go into a
stellar stage you look you what comes
before what does the historical ven
become before the scripture orders the
scripture would come come before the
historical event obviously the
historical get okay so now what is the
scripture that you accept if you're
saying you don't like the old mean old
testament mean and there's something
wrong in the old test you don't like it
something's wrong how could you not like
read and go to it you see this in our
tradition if someone said I don't like
with the Quran I mean I'll be thinking
is this guy a Muslim is this guy even a
Muslim how could you not like her in the
Quran why because there's some things in
it that this comes for you you know
there are some injunctions let's we
found it fair and honest in some
injunctions which are very similar
within the Old Testament and the Quran
they're very similar injunctions but for
someone now to reject the Quran as a
result of this
is problematic because for our from our
perspective the epistemology is you go
back to the Creator God who created the
world and who sent prophets of which
Jesus is one of them Moses Jesus Abraham
etc and Muhammad is the final prophet of
all of those prophets and whatever he
comes with is why he is revelation and
therefore anything he says must be
concurrent with the absolute truth with
the objective truth that's a simple that
is a simple customization of Islamic
belief so someone says I don't like
reading those injunctions those points
of guidance then for me that person has
not been it has not believed in those
parts of guidance
so I'm really shocked that you can have
someone who's in the apologetics or
whatever you want to call it in the
Christian apology what you want to call
whatever they do and they are speaking
like that and the crowd is swallowing it
up it's clapping along it shows you the
state of Christianity in the West has
reached an all-time low I probably say
that has reached an all-time low since
probably like a thousand years honestly
people are just willing to accept krupka
clutch on any kind of straw to maintain
their faith in these doctrines which
have now largely become outdated for the
majority when the opinion of the
majority of was becoming a majority by
the way I'm not saying as the majority
just yet but in probably about twenty
years it would definitely
jury of Weston Westerners anyways
cinematic come on - why